the fields are on fire in eastern
ukraine
homes have been pummeled the factories
ablaze
as the russians move on two cities here
severo donetsk and its twin lucy chansk
and all those who come here must make
this unnerving drive
we are exposed here
this is probably the most dangerous part
of the trip and
the russians can see us from their
positions and
and people are trying to do it as
quickly as they can
we've come to lucidchans to meet the
famed commander of a battalion now
fighting for these cities
a former politician called petro kuzik
he directs operations from this bunker
and we found him casting an eye over a
shipment of shoulder-borne missiles
your men know how to use these
very easy
he likes the spanish model it's only got
one safety catch but he says he's going
to need some bigger kit
no patriotism
he says the russians have 20 times the
number of tanks and artillery and 10
times more troops
the threat is ever present
there are drones in the air and
unexploded missiles on the ground
city residents have learned to weave
around them
one hundred thousand used to live here
but now just a few souls call it home
but the situation's worse on the other
side of the river
we're now
it's not very far
here's what ukrainian troops are doing
in severo donetsk
it's a brutal contest for the inner city
these pictures provided two sky news by
the battalion
russian tanks opened fire at close range
and their artillery pounds apartment
blocks and businesses
but the ukrainians have dug in retaining
40 to 60 percent of the city depending
on the day says the commander
although it isn't
troops told us that the last bridge
connecting the two cities was destroyed
over a week ago
so they've come up with a fix boats with
ropes across the river
it may be dangerous but it seems to work
is
[Music]
who would choose to stay in this
beleaguered spot
the president of ukraine has called them
the dead cities but thousands remain
despite attempts to evacuate them
why why are you still here
why haven't you left
look the police the police have been
evacuating people the police will get
you out
here
a soldier does his best to persuade them
to leave and there's little time
their commander fears a catastrophe if a
nearby chemical plant explodes
and they know the battle for these
cities may have only just begun
john sparks sky news in lucichansk